hey guys so hi I'm John Humphrey and
welcome to headless reaction
what's up reject nation of John Humphrey
coming at you there's a new King's Men
the Golden Circle teaser trailer a TV
spot rather out and hey man let's take a
look at that someone's done something
major the name the Golden Circle keeps
coming up fingerprints repeating once
asked me at twelve made at 24 karat gold
[Music]
Wow
this is coming oh man all right I mean
that was nice that was pretty slight but
I am excited that we were seeing more
Julianne Moore's character she's
probably the thing I'm looking forward
to most about this movie I mean I think
she's a terrific actress and I am really
excited to see her sink her teeth into
something more along line to basically
like a Bond villain let seems like an
oddly clever piece of marketing because
they're taking advantage of the actual
solar eclipse that's supposed to take
place to tomorrow morning I don't think
I've ever seen anything like that before
and if you're making a movie about a
diabolical supervillain hey why not I
mean that's actually a pretty cool twist
yeah I mean I'm looking forward to this
movie I liked the first Kingsman a good
amount I'm glad that they're playing up
the villain more in this trailer I feel
like a lot of the advertising has been
geared towards the Statesmen side of
things but what I do like about this is
that it is getting directly into
Julianne Moore's character poppy and her
poppy land compound this mysterious
looking you know almost like a Johnny
Rockets compound that she's got going
here even though we've only had a few
small glimpses and stuff like that I
really get a great sense for who her
character is but they are taking the
time to build her up as incredibly
powerful and pretty dangerous it seems
like and what I admire about the
Kingsmen movies thus far anyway is the
imagination that comes to these I mean
they're kind of keeping alive the more
fun side of what you used to love about
bond but with you know Matthew Vaughn
very kinetic and hyper violent style
like I like what they're doing with this
I don't adore the first movie but I saw
it again just recently and I think it's
really fun I think it's really clever
and this movie I'm getting pretty
excited for and Julianne Moore is a big
part of that I'm interested to see more
than this little tease here at least
expands a little bit on what the
universe is going to look like the
sinister operation burning up and your
prison filing down teeth and anonymity
and pure gold circle tattoos like
they're really taking up the mantle of
making these big over-the-top high
concept you know world wide villainy
espionage tales and I'm enjoying that
about the Kingsmen so this is pretty
cool so yeah what do you guys think
comment below let me know your thoughts
and as always I am Det John Humphrey on
Twitter and Instagram you can subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification bell to get notified every
time a review or video is out you can
also check us out on patreon we got a
whole bunch of cool
and fun content going on over there a
lot of nice people come over there get
accepted as we used to say also got
t-shirts in our Spreadshirt store thank
you much for watching and until next
time yeah six in post